And I'm I,
I believe that to be the case.
So your platform restricts speech.
Our platform promotes speech unless
people violate our rules and in a specific
direction, in any direction. But uncle,
oh, I don't want to say his name.
The guy who calls for
death gets a suspension.
The guy who insinuates
that gets a permanent ban.
You're misinterpreting what I'm
saying and I feel like you're doing it
deliberately.
It's not about one particular thing.
It's about a pattern in practice of
violating our pattern and practice of
banding.
Only one faction of [inaudible] recently
published an article where they looked
at 22 high profile bandings from 2015 and
found 21 of them were only on one side
of the cultural debate,
but I don't look at the political spectrum
of people when I'm looking at their
tweets. You have a volume,
you're biased and you are,
you're targeting specific individuals
because your rules support this
perspective. No, I don't agree with that.
Can you be clear though in like what
rules support that for specifically?
The easiest one is mis-gendering, right,
because that's so clearly ideological.
If you ask a conservative
what is mis-gendering,
they'll say if someone is biologically
male and you call them, you know,
she a biological man and you call
them mushy. That's mis-gender.
And as a conservative view, the, the,
the progressive view is inverted.
So now you actually have in your
policies a rule against the conservative
perspective.
I have a rule against the
abuse and harassment of
trans people on our platform.
That's what my role is.
We just give context in the
background as to why the why that is.
And I brought some,
some research.
So we obviously received
a lot of feedback.
So we don't make these roles in a vacuum.
And just to be clear,
we have a bunch of people all around the
world to give us contacts and the types
of behavior they're seeing, how that
translates into real world harm. And uh,
they give us feedback and they tell us
like you should consider different types
of rules, different types of perspectives,
different. Like, for example,
when we try to enforce hateful conduct
in a are hateful conduct policy and your
particular country,
we are not going to know all the slur
words that are used to target people of a
particular race or a particular religion.
So we're going to rely on building out
a team of experts all around the world
who are going to help us enforce our
rules. So in the particular case of, um,
mis-gendering, I'm just trying to pull
up some of the studies that we looked at,
but we looked at,
um,
the American Association of Pediatrics
and looked at the number of transgender
youths that were committing suicide.
It's an astronomical,
and I'm sorry I can't find it right
now in front of me. It's a really,
really high statistic.
That's like 10 times with the normal
suicide rate is of normal teenagers.
And we looked at the causes of what that
was happening and a lot of it was not
just violence towards those individuals,
but it was bullying behavior and what was,
what,
why are those bullying behaviors
that were contributing to that?
And that's why we made this rule because
we thought and we believe that those
types of behaviors were happening on
our platform and we wanted to stop it.
Now there are exceptions to this
rule. We don't, and this is all,
this isn't about like public figures
and there's always going to be public
figures that you're going to want to
talk about and that's, that's fine.
But this is about are
you doing something with
the intention of abusing and harassing
a trans person on the platform and are
they viewing it that way and reporting
it to us so that we take action. So,
so I will just state, I actually agree
with the rule on from my point of view,
I agree that bullying and harassing
Trans People's in higher, entirely wrong.
I disagree with it,
but I just want to make sure it's
clear to everybody who's listening.
My point is simply that,
you know,
Ben Shapiro went on a talk show and
absolutely refused and that's his shtick.
You know, and he's one of the
biggest podcasts in the world.
So if you have all of his millions upon
millions of followers who are looking at
this rule saying,
this goes against my view of the world
and it's literally 60 plus million in
this country, you do have a rule that's
ideologically bent and, and it's,
it's true. You, you did the
research, you believe this.
Well then you have Ben Shapiro who did
his recent research and doesn't believe
it. Yeah. And I relied on
the American Association of
Pediatrics and uh, you know,
human rights council and other,
and I'm sure he has his sources too,
for when he gives his statements.
The point is a bundle of iots wonder
if they have that context. I mean,
and that's,
and that's where we have also,
it's just explaining the why
behind a lot of eyeballs.
Soon reasons I would agree.
And I think it's fine.
You did research and you
found this to be true,
but we can't simply say maybe Ben Shapiro
and the other conservatives who feel
this way, don't know. We have
two W W we can't, you know,
the point I'm trying to make is
simply whether you believe it,
whether you justified or not is
not the point. The point is you do,
you do have this rule. That rule is at
odds with conservative superior. Well,
I think, I think that
you're, you're generalizing,
but I think it is really important. As
Jack said to the why behind these things,
the why is to protect people
from abuse and harassment.
I understand what you essentially created
a protected class. If this is the case,
because despite these
studies and what you know,
the studies are showing there's a gigantic
suicide rate amongst trans people,
period. It's a 40% it's,
it's outrageously large. Now,
whether that is because of
gender dysphoria with us
because of the complications
from sexual surgery, sexual transition
surgery, whether it's because of bullying,
whether it's because of this awful
feeling of being born in the wrong gender,
whether that all that
is yet to be determined.
The fact that they've shown that there's
a large amount of trans people that are
committing suicide.
I don't necessarily think that that makes,
that makes sense in terms of
people from someone's perspective,
like a Ben Shapiro saying that
if you are biologically female,
if you are born with
a double x chromosome,
you will never be x,
y if he says that that's,
that's a violation of your policy and
this is you're creating a protected class,
it'd be to be fair,
targeted or, or targeting.
So conduct that opinion.
So what if he said [inaudible]
entitled to express that opinion.
If he's doing in a manner that's
targeted at an individual repeatedly,
repeatedly, repeatedly,
and saying, okay, but what
about the intent? What's going on
with Martina Navratilova right now?
Martina Navratilova Rollover. Why? Why
can I say her last name now? But yeah,
I don't even have a truck.
I don't think I've ever said it.
Martina Novotal to lovo is it
tall over Trello? Trello's anyway,
epic World Class Legend Tennis Player,
right?
Who happens to be a lesbian is,
um,
being harassed because she says that
she doesn't believe that trans women,
meaning someone who was biologically male,
who transitions to a female should
be able to compete in sports against
biological females.
This is something that I agree with.
This is something I have personally
experienced a tremendous amount of
harassment because I stood up when there
was a woman who was a trans woman who
was fighting biological females in
mixed martial arts fights and destroying
these women.
And I was saying,
what did you just watch this and tell
me this doesn't look crazy to you? Um,
well, I go, go, go ahead. Well,
my point is you should be able to
express yourself in if you say that you
believe someone is biologically male,
even though they identify as a female,
that's a perspective that should be valid.
I mean that this is someone's,
someone's, this is, first of
all, it's biologically correct.
So we have a problem in that.
If your standards and your policies
are not biologically accurate,
then you're dealing with an ideological,
I'd, you know, an ideological policy.
And just because, I mean, I don't,
I don't want to target trans people.
I don't want to harass him. I certainly,
I'll call anybody whatever they want.
I mean,
if you want to change your name to a
woman's name and identify as a woman,
I'm 100% cool with that.
But by saying,
I don't think that you should
be able to compete as a woman,
this opens me up for harassment
and I never recorded any of it.
I just don't pay attention to it.
But yeah,
in going into like Megan
Murphy for instance, right?
You can call that target harassment if
Megan Murphy who is a, for those that are,
don't,
don't know,
she's a radical feminist who refuses
to use the transgender pronouns.
If she's in an argument with a trans
person over whether or not they should be
allowed in sports or in biologically
female spaces and she refuses to use their
pronoun because of her ideology,
you'll bend them. Again,
it depends on the context on the platform.
And it's also,
I want not banned permanently
like you get. Yeah,
well she was banned permanently.
But listen,
she was warned you about what happened
because he explained it to me.
What did she actually do?
My understanding,
and I don't have the tweet by tweet
the way that I did for the others,
but my understanding is that she
was warned multiple times for um,
mis-gendering an individual that
she was in an argument with.
And this individual is actually bringing
a lawsuit against her in Canada as well.
So you have an argument
between two people. Again,
I have a rule that enforces only one side
of the ideology and you've banned only
one of those people. We have a rule
that attempts to address what we
have perceived to be instances
of abuse and harassment
ideology, right? If she's
saying a man is never a woman,
if that's what she's saying.
And then biologically she's correct.
We obviously have a debate here.
This is not a clear cut.
This is not something like you could say
water is wet, you know, this is dry. It's,
and this is not like
something you can prove.
This is something where you have to
acknowledge that there's an understanding
that if someone has a trans person,
we all agree to consider them a woman and
to think of them as a woman to talk to
them and address them with their preferred
name and their preferred pronouns.
But biologically this is not accurate.
So we have, we have a divide here.
We have a divide between the conservative
estimation of what's happening and
then the definition.
That's the liberal definition of it.
I think that's right Joe.
And I think what I'm trying to say is
that it's not that you can't have those
viewpoints,
it's that if you're taking
those viewpoints and you're
targeting at them at a
specific person in a way that reflects
your intent to abuse and harass them,
what if it's in the context
of the conversation?
What if she's saying that I don't think
that trans women should be allowed in
these female spaces to
make decisions for women.
And then this person's arguing and she
says, a woman is biologically female.
You are never going to be a woman. She
responded with men aren't women though.
And that was her first
in the series of events.
That's what got her the
suspension and the warning. Um,
that was one of many tweets that part of
providing context and that was actually
the second, second actually strike is my
understanding. But why is that a strike?
Yeah, why is that a, strike that. But
again, like it's the context of I don't,
I don't have all the trees in front of me.
They were like 10 or 12 tweets going back
and forth and my understanding is that
in that context of all of those,
she was mis-gendering a particular person.
Not that she was holding a was above
her statement, wasn't it? I don't know.
It was. So you don't, you're having,
you're having an individual who was
debating a high profile individual in her
community and she's expressing her,
her ideology of versus hers and you have
opted to ban one of those ideologies.
It's within the context of
this conversation. This is,
this is what is being debated.
Whether or not someone is in fact
a woman when they were born a male.
I understand that this is controversial.
I do.
I especially to a radical feminists,
someone who I understand why,
why people would not agree with the rule,
but that being said,
it is a rule on our platform and once
you're warned about the rule to repeatedly
post the same content is also going
to be a violation of our rules. Right?
But the rule,
it's,
this seems like a good example of
an ideologically based rule. If,
if you're, if she's saying that
a man is never a woman though,
that is not in that context harassment.
That is a very specific opinion that
she has that happens to be biologically
accurate. Now, I don't, you know,
I don't agree with targeting harassment
on anybody and I targeted harassment on
trans people or, or straight people or
whatever. I don't, I don't agree with it.
I don't think you should do it. It's,
it's not something I want to do.
But in this context,
what she saying is not just
her, her expression, but it's accurate.
I think an important point is
if I tweet it to you, Joe, Joe,
you are not a hamster. That's clearly
not a violation of the rules. However,
there are identify as a hamster. Well,
no, it wouldn't be clear cause I know a,
I know people who have specifically
begun using insults of animals to avoid
getting kicked off the platform
for breaking the rules.
Certain individuals who have been
suspended now use certain small woodland
creatures in place of slurs, so they're
not really insulting you and it's fine,
but there are people who
considers himself trans species.
Now I'm not trying to belittle
the trans community by no means.
I'm just trying to point out that you
have a specific rule for one set of people
and they're there. They're so, there are
people who have general body dysphoria.
You don't have rules on that.
There are people who have
actually amputated their own arms.
You don't have rules on that.
You have a very specific rule set.
And in more importantly,
in the context of a targeted conversation,
I can say a whole bunch of things that
would never be considered a rural break.
But that one is,
which is ideologically driven.
Yeah. Thank you for that
feedback. I mean we're,
we're again always learning and I'm
trying to understand different people's
perspectives and I'll,
all I'll say is that our intent is not
to police ideology or intent as to police
behaviors that we view as
abuse, movement, harassment.
And I hear your point of view and it's
something that I'll definitely discuss
with my team.
And, and even in this case
it was, it wasn't just um,
a going against this particular rule,
but also things that were
more ban evasive as well,
including taking a screenshot of
the original tweet, reposting it,
which is against our terms.
It sounds like it's more of the accident.
It sounded like a protest
against your role.
I understand you to band them for it,
but people can protest any
one of our rules. We can't,
we can't like let them do that.
No, no, no. I haven't purchased
any of that. Data is great.
I understand what you're saying,
but I just want to make sure I point out
she was clearly doing it as an effort
to push back on what she viewed as an
ideologically driven role. Well, this is
problem is,
this is a real debate
in the LGBT community.
This is a debate where there is a division
and there's a division between people
that think that Trans Women are invading
biological female spaces and making
decisions that don't benefit these
biological females, cisgender,
whatever you want to call them. This
is an actual debate and it's a debate,
a debate amongst progressive people
amongst left wing people. I mean,
it's a debate amongst
liberals. This is, I mean,
I would imagine the vast
majority of people in the
LBGT community are in fact on
the left.
And this is one example of that.
So you have a protected class that's
having an argument with a woman who feels
like there's an ideological bent
to this conversation that is not,
not only not accurate,
but not fair.
And she feels like it's not fair for
biological women. The same as Martina.
Well, I'll, I'll, uh, take
this to its logical conclusion.
I got sent a screenshot from somebody and
maybe it's faked. I think it was real.
They were having an argument with someone
on Twitter and responded with, Dude,
comma, you don't know, blah, blah blah,
and they got a suspension and a lockout
have delete the tweet because the
individual using a cartoon Avatar with
the eight with with the name apparently
with Sam reported it and said that I'm
transgender and he's calling me dude and
the dude and the Twitter user
actually got a suspension for it.
So I can understand mistakes happen.
But when you have a rule that's like that,
there's colloquial terms that are
like, man, come on. Don't say that
dude is like, we say like, oh,
like I asked you guys when you were going
to take a photo in front of this thing.
I said, guys, but I included, you
know, thank you for not being offended.
You for it. Thank you.
Yeah, it's, it's tricky.
But in this case of Megan Murphy, that's
her name, right? Yeah. Yeah, I did.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
That seems like she should be allowed to
express herself in this is this is not
being, she's not being mean, but
I saying a man is never a woman.
This is a perspective that that is
scientifically accurate and that's,
that's part of the problem.
I th I, I, I just don't want it to
run into a beating a dead horse.
So I think I want to,
let's say it's a really important thing
to go over all the nuances of this
particular subject because I think that
one in particular highlights this idea
of where the problems lie
and having a protected class.
And I think that we should
be compassionate. We have
a lot of protected classes,
gender, race, nationality, like these are
the protected class, not for white people.
When you say gender or race,
it's not all protected categories.
So you can't attack someone for their
belonging to a particular race or a
particular religion. But
you can mock white people ad
nauseum. It's not a problem.
It doesn't get, it doesn't get
removed. I'm not talking about mocking,
I'm talking about abusing
and harassing some,
but I mean if you mock a black person
in the same way it would be considered
targeted racism. Um, again,
it's about targeted harassment
on the platform, but well,
I mean can do what is targeted harassment.
I mean, but when you're okay, look,
if you have,
what is racism is racism own image.
There's this progressive perspective of
racism that it's only possible if you're
from a more powerful class only
punching down. That's the only racism.
I don't think that makes any sense.
I think racism is looking at
someone that is from whatever,
whatever race and deciding that they
are in fact less or less worthy or less
valuable,
whatever it is that that takes place
across the platform against white people.
Now I'm not saying white
people need to be protected.
I know it's easier being a white
person in America. It's a fact,
but it's hypocritical to have a
policy that only distinguishes,
you can make fun of white
people all day long.
But if you decide to make fun
of Asian folks or you know,
fill in the blank that is racist,
but making fun of white people
isn't and it doesn't get removed.
There are tons of people like about
Sarah John from the New York Times.
That's a of, well I can
explain that one. Please
do.
There's that was uh,
my understanding is that you guys started
banning people officially under these
policies around 2015 and those,
all the tweets you made was prior to that.
And so you didn't enforce the old
sorry, hateful conduct policy. Joe, just
to be clear is, is across the board,
meaning like it doesn't just protect
women and protects men and women and
protects all races.
It doesn't matter.
And this is how the law is set
up in the United States, right?
You can't discriminate against white men.
You can't discriminate against black
men. Like those are the laws, right?
Like that's the structure. It
is. That doesn't, it doesn't
take into consideration.
Power one says something about white
people in mocks, white people on Twitter.
What do you do about that? If it's
targeted harassment targeted at a person.
So just white people in general.
If you say something about why people in
general that's on an issue that, well,
I mean we focus on targeted harassment,
which is behavior that is targeted
against an individual who belongs to that
class.
Okay.
Because if you try to police every
opinion that people have about different
races or religions, like obviously
that's a very different story.
So this is about if you target that to
somebody who belongs to that class and
that's reported to us, that is a violation
of our rules. And so in this era,
Jiang case, a lot, we
did see many tweets, uh,
of that nature that we're focused on.
Uh,
people who are white or men and our rules
are in this area came into effect in
2015 which was our hateful conduct policy.
And a lot of those tweets were from a
time period where those rules weren't an,
in her defense.
She was actually supposedly
responding to people that have,
you don't believe that I'll come on over
three years and she's tweeting blanket
statements about white. Yeah, sure,
sure. But so, so I will say too,
obviously I've done it.
I at one point,
so in that case,
there were tweets from before the rules
went into effect in tweets from after
the rules went into effect.
And we did take action on the tweets
from after the rules went into.
She's also pretty young, so I want
to point, uh, yeah, she's in her 20s.
Yeah. So we're talking about something
that might've happened eight years ago,
right? Right. It's a 20. It was like 2011
to 13. But I do want to point this out.
Um, before coming on, I've
obviously did at time,
I did a decent amount of research.
I searched for slurs against white people,
black people, Latinos, and I found
copious, just, just tons and tons of them.
Now they don't go back.
Most of what I found in go back too far,
because it does seem like
you guys are doing your best,
but there is a lot and it targets white
people, black people, Jewish people.
It's everybody,
right.